التظاهرات تتواصل وسلطات الايرانيه ترد
تصعيد يفاجئ النظام الباحث عن مخرج ولو
بكي نفسه
مجبرا ينظر النظام في امكانيه تخفيف بعض
القيود على النساء
الاخيره على خطط لاصلاح انفاذ القوانين
المتعلقه بملابس النساء
لكن ثبت اسئله كثيره مطروحه حول تلك
التوجهات لا سيما في مدى جديه النظام على
التغيير والى اين يمكن ان يذهب لا تفاصيل
حول الاصلاحات المجمعه غير انما رشا حيشي
بتغليظ الغرامات الماليه والتخفيف من
الاحتجاز والاستجواب
محاولات تبدو حظوظ نجاحها على الارض غير
مضمونه فالاحتجاجات مستمره والاضطرابات
تتوالى حتى ان القرار الاخير بحل شرطه
الاخلاق لم يكن كافيا ولا مقنعا
للمتظاهرين
توجه مشكوك فيه خصوصا في ما يمس اسس
عقائديه يقوم عليها النظام اصلا وهو ما
بدا واضحا في كلام الرئيس الايراني اسس
الجمهوريه راسخه في الدستور اما المورونه
في وسائل تطبيقه كما يقول وهي وسائل لا
يثق بها المحتجون اساسا